how's it go breath but it it's Monday
it's shitty weather everyone is feeling
down I wanted to make a video where I
make people a little happier out there
and what better way to do that than to
force it up on them so if we're gonna do
what I like to call the fab eliezer all
right so I'm gonna take suggestions on
Twitter and the who - okay so a lot of
you suggested Barack Obama so that's
what we're gonna do so you want to start
by selecting which photo - fabulous so I
thought we'd take one all right he
doesn't look so fabulous
good work with this you got that smile
baby okay this is before now let's work
our way through this what a man with a
great smile needs it's some great
muscles I think you look way better
already
Obama don't you at the show Obama isn't
gay nice nice golden features okay
that's pretty attractive I think for for
him I know what would look even better
there we go one-mississippi
two-mississippi three-mississippi what
am i doing okay what else
Obama is a king without a crown so let's
give him what he deserves what am i
doing I hope Obama doesn't see this I
hope no one would ever do this to me all
right
that looks pretty good I think we are
almost done I just want to do some
touch-up effect now we do what I like to
call the shameful effects don't know why
I'm doing this
don't don't look at me like that god
dammit I'm not gay
I promise all right I think this is
pretty much a good results let's take a
look at before before and after before
after my step do you want to look at it
the they said I was gonna do Obama this
is before and this is after I like the
piercings I want his nipples you can't
really see let's see what the bros think
what your breath stink about is on
Twitter - ten out of ten did not Kawai
what da [ __ ] 34 ducks out at 35 that's
pretty good
tell heaven rainbows out of seven nice
okay all right let's move on to the next
one next up we got dr. Phil and Phil
good old Phil is already very fabulous I
mean he's rocking that moustache he's
got a beautiful I don't know some what's
the ease I they're totally out of
proportion who photoshopped this alright
let's make something out of this just
cuz I found this and oh god I gotta save
this one this I think I think this video
might give some people nightmares ah as
two clothes fell and it's way too close
oh god this looks terrifying god please
forgive me for my sins oh oh nice Oh God
Oh God okay make it stop
God where does Phil's [ __ ] Shin ends how
am I supposed to work with this Oh God
this is actually terrifying me a little
bit not gonna lie I don't know why but
this this picture makes me want to cry
I don't know why just a small time Phil
living in a no it looks like the hair is
growing on his back or some [ __ ] like
that okay so now we're done I feel
generally uncomfortable doing this like
I my body is just saying no
but the rest is saying yes I mean he's a
very attractive woman I don't know what
to say he needs something else you know
with women these days it's all about
twerking there we go got that booty
uh-huh
looking good there dr. Phil man you
should go ahead into modeling if you
ever actually don't that's pretty
attractive
okay Matt say you can look this one but
honestly I don't know if it's a good
idea so you know this man it's dr. Phil
he's like a famous talk show host for
I'm thinking if I did it too much yeah I
figured he wanted a Nicki Minaj one
that's our before-and-after
all right so now let's see what you bros
would rate this superhot 10 out of 10
that is though
I'm emotional so fabulous next up we got
Miley none under what that what there
really isn't much to shop here how about
we try and make her less skanky yes I
can totally see inspiration inspiration
okay this is a start I just think I have
a talent to just see what people for
what they really are I'm just gonna work
with this okay I think we have a pretty
nice result here so far don't know what
else I could do with this to be honest
how about we just actually now I'm
getting really inspired
[Music]
[Music]
I realize now that this is not much of a
fabulous or it's more like a [ __ ] I
don't know what I don't even know I
honestly this is where my brain went I I
don't even I can't even Lily this is
where my brain has gone with all the
father's like I haven't checked up any
goddamn it I need help okay here's
another wonderful end result so here we
go before fabulae sir after it's some
[ __ ] that what is wrong with me there's
Miley before and then after
that's the soul of Hannah Montana I'm an
egg yeah this this is art 10,000 torques
holy [ __ ] that's awesome
I don't see a difference honey boo boo
yeah my big good one an improvement to
say the least
see one more let's do one more because I
actually love the Photoshop it's so to
finish off we're gonna do smash because
they made a Photoshop video where they
Photoshop me okay I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm gonna do with this honestly
give me a little time and I got
something I could work with oh man Ian
yeah and you look good
yeah yeah hello how much Ian is just
blending in right away should I give him
the god that's disturbing
Oh God okay so I want Anthony's eyes to
look on his badonk as' that's beautiful
beautiful but Uncas and that should be
able to fix I love when I one eyes fixed
look so good let's do the other one
this is hope he's looking at him close
enough now this picture has [ __ ] quality
so we're gonna have to fix it a little
bit alright it's pretty good now it's
just missing one thing
no no no why no no are you kidding me
okay so I'm back I did ian's nip and I
managed to save whatever I could I don't
feel like redoing everything but we are
going to finish this [ __ ] up I don't
know what happened there really don't
want to know okay we're done
Mott's yeah this is Ian Smosh and
Anthony before yes
I don't know and
hey it looks good oh hey I was like we
shouldn't see that foot but he an is on
that side and Anthony is on that side I
don't know I think it looks pretty hot
what don't know I think it's a necklace
and it messed up when I change the
quality well I I think I had enough fun
for today I don't know what this is
exactly I don't it's this video type of
video is still in beta or whatever but
maybe like if you enjoyed or if you want
to see something similar or more and
I'll see you in the next one
stay awesome bros love you can I talk
good night George
okay this what's that it's not even a
backflip
[Music]